Julie rouet a composé la musique
originale de la fille de son père un
film d'Erwan Leduc présenté en clôture
de la semaine de la critique du Festival
de Cannes c'est une musique plutôt
impressionniste moi j'étais assez
inspirée enfin en toute modestie par
Debussy Ravel ce genre de compositeur et
ces musiques qui est aussi intimiste
dans le sens où il y a assez peu
d'instruments et où elle essaye de
coller au plus proche à au personnage
principaux qui ont une histoire de
famille donc voilà très intime on parle
d'une histoire ou un père et sa fille ne
communique pas il s'aime très fort mais
on sent qu'il y a plein de non-dits en
fait la musique vient un peu dire ce que
ce qui ne se dise pas et donc c'est un
peu tous les conflits tout ce qui
ressentent à l'intérieur qui qui doivent
passer par le ns oui lumière et le
conservatoire du neuvième arrondissement
de Paris Julie rouet a composé la
musique d'une soixantaine de films tout
au long de sa carrière
j'ai commencé en fait ma carrière comme
ingénieur du son j'ai été monté son au
cinéma pendant plusieurs années on peut
commencer à composer en parallèle et au
bout d'une dizaine d'années j'ai pu me
consacrer uniquement à la musique de
film Le son qu'il a pris dans une école
qui s'appelle Louis Lumière qui est une
école où il y a à la fois des gens qui
prennent le son et d'autres qui
apprennent le cinéma et donc c'est
vraiment un peu par hasard en fait que
j'ai commencé à faire de la musique pour
les travaux des étudiants au cinéma
Julie ouais compose également des
musiques personnelles ou sonorité pop
elle est aussi membre du groupe avion
avec lequel elle se produit en spectacle
et depuis peu elle travaille sur un
projet de jeux vidéo en réalité
virtuelle